séparatisme communautarisme intégration
terroriste laïcité en parle de tout ça
avec le politologue frédéric sinclair
analystes en stratégie et en
communication politique et auteur du
livre la droite face à l'islam aux
éditions salvateur bonjour frédéric
saint clair merci de répondre à nos
questions un texte donc amputé des
termes séparatisme singulier ou au
pluriel un islamisme en quoi cette
nouvelle appellation confortant les
principes républicains peut-elle
satisfaire la place politiques
françaises et les français
vous vous êtes un spécialiste en
communication politique en changeant cet
intitulé écoute de la communication
gouvernementale bien quid de
l'affaissement l'affaiblissement vous
l'avez mentionné en creux partir du
moment où on renonce à nommer ce que
emmanuel macron lui-même disait qu'ils
étaient le principal ennemi c'est à dire
l'islamisme le séparatisme islamistes et
en enlevant ces deux termes ont renoncé
à nommer l'ennemi est donc en renonçant
à nommer on recommence d'une certaine
manière à le combattre
qu'il s'agisse de communication ou
d'actes donc c'est durcir mais en même
temps ne pas stigmatiser c'est ça c'est
encore du duo en même temps de la part
de l'exécutif le la faiblesse de de tous
les gouvernements depuis une bonne
quarantaine d'années en france et
peut-être même plus largement dans dans
l'europe de l'ouest est liée au cadre
social libéral qui l'ont construit et
qui est extrêmement protecteur des
libertés individuelles extrêmement
soucieux des libertés fondamentales
il ne faut toucher ni aux humains ni aux
autres ni de près ni de loin et donc à
partir du moment où on entend faire la
guerre sans à un moment égratigné le
socle des libertés fondamentales
on a un véritable problème vous l'avez
remarqué en écoutant parler le garde des
sceaux il ya quelques instants
entendue trois fois que ce texte était
un texte de liberté ça a été repris par
différents ministres malaise qui a pas
notamment donc cet attachement aux
libertés cette volonté de ne pas
stigmatiser pose un réel problème en
matière de défense donc ce texte c'est
un peu la ligne maginot de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
tout le monde y croit tout le monde en
parle elle est là elle est grande elle
est majestueuse mais henry lesquelles sa
part rien le député les républicains
eric diard auteur d'un rapport
parlementaire sur la radicalisation avec
le député l om eric boullier se félicite
quand même du nouveau des livres danger
de la vie d'autrui un parent diffusion
d'imagés relatives à la vie privée ou
familiale il déplore l'absence de
mesures à l'université dans les prisons
ou sur la santé quelle est votre
réaction vous qui avait été conseiller
du premier ministre dominique de
villepin qu'est-ce que vous proposeriez
alors je ne propose plus depuis que je
suis sorti dessus du cabinet du premier
ministre n'est plus mon rôle en revanche
ce que je fais c'est que j'observe la
vie politique et surtout j'observe que
les problématiques que nous connaissons
depuis vingt ans se sont
considérablement durci en 2007
là nicolas sarkozy s'était fait élire
déjà sur un problème de sécurité mais il
ne parlait pas encore de la
problématique islamistes donc on peut
mesurer par exemple le décalage entre
les banlieues de l'islam qu'ils ont
écrite par gilles kepel en 1987
donc on voit quel point les
intellectuels étaient précurseurs dans
notre pays et puis la réponse politique
qui arrive faiblement entre 2010 et 2020
ou la classe politique commence à se
soucier un tout petit peu plus de cet
islamisme qui aujourd'hui avec près de
300 morts dans notre pays due au
terrorisme et avec une prise de
conscience depuis les attentats de nice
et la décapitation de samuel pâtit de là
l'importance de l'environnement du
terreau on se rend compte finalement de
la faiblesse du texte à dire que ce
n'est pas que les mesures de ce texte ne
sont pas en soit utile bien évidemment
qu'elles sont utiles c'est que
simplement c'est pour ça que je parlais
de la ligne maginot c'est que simplement
mettrait
très loin de la réponse attendue face à
l'unfp à la puissance de la menace est
son importance
on devrait aujourd'hui réellement entrer
dans une législation qui bouscule l'état
de droit non pas qu'ils renoncent à
l'état de droit mais qu'ils le
transforment qu'il adapte pour
réellement lutter contre la menace et on
se rend bien compte que ces mesures là
qui sont des réponses très très faible
on parle de tests de virginité pour les
enfants on parle de mariage de polygamie
on parle de mariage forcé on parle des
d'écoles coraniques qui serait contrôlée
d'associations sportif
le simple fait de vouloir contrôler une
association sportive est une gageur en
réalité qui va aller dans les milliers
d'associations sportives de france au
creux des quartiers toutes les semaines
vérifier qu est ce qui se dit et qu'est
ce qui se dit pas c'est impossible donc
c'est un voeu pieux tu as un certain
nombre d'articles
il n'y a pas de réelle volonté de
bloquer la poussée en croissance de
l'islamisme en france et donc ça veut
dire quoi c'est à dire que les français
savent très bien que l'islamisation de
la société va se poursuivre et sa loge
air de dire que c'est ce noël qu'il faut
dire que ce projet de loi n'est pas
n'est pas applicable
c'est ça fredericks en clair ce que vous
êtes en train de dire oui c'est
exactement ça sert jeudi qu'en fait ce
droit était un voeu pieux parce qu'il a
il porte en lui la faiblesse de son de
son application
prenons un exemple très concret à partir
du moment où la question de la
libération des terroristes qui étaient
en prison c'est s'est posé on sait qu'il
y a plusieurs centaines de terroristes
qui vont être libérés quand déjà
commencé à libérer qui vont être libérés
dans les années qui viennent
immédiatement la vox populis et 10 mai
mais comment comment maîtriser cette
cette menace en puissance et qui conduit
les acteurs politiques il n'est pas
possible de mettre 1 1 un policier
derrière chaque terroriste et de
contrôler tout le monde qu'il ya une
vraie menace est une vraie acceptation
de la menace est donc la réponse a été
quoi il faut nous habituer à vivre avec
le terrorisme c'est exactement la même
chose avec l'islamisme comme il n'est
pas possible de mettre un gendarme
derrière chaque association et de
vérifier chaque propos qui est tenu il
le message qui est distribué aux
français c'est il va falloir vous
habituer
à vivre avec l'islamisme merci frédéric
sinclair je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue alain l'histoire en
stratégie en communication politique et
auteur notamment du livre la droite face
à l'islam aux éditions salvator